James starts out this hour in North
Carolina hi James how are you I'm doing
fantastic Dave how about yourself better
than I deserve
what's up okay so I'm a college student
and I was just listening to uh the guy
you had on before I'm talking about
high school students and college
students and I just wanted to know of
ways that I could save money and stay
out of debt and still you know work part
well I'm working for our time now going
to school and now you know and right now
I'm saving up to uh to move into my
first apartment so you know just
thinking about the future and thinking
about tuition cost and you know I just
wanted to get some advice on that well I
think what you've got is prioritize and
calendar eyes your expenditures by that
I mean you know getting your first
apartment after you get out is not as
important as getting out yes sir so
we're going to say all right the first
thing is going to be you know more
tuition the final set of books finishing
the career finishing the degree before
we start the career that's going to be
you know the first priority and the
first thing that comes up on the
calendar and so we go I need money for
that before I need money for I need
money for X before I need money for Y
and I need Y before I do Z and so you
lay Connor out an order and then that
begins to give you an attack mode and
then you put dollar amounts beside those
things and you compare that to the
income you're creating and go hey how am
I going to do this you know I have a two
thousand dollar expenditure coming up I
make five hundred bucks how am I going
to do that two thousand dollars I got to
work towards that right or I got it you
know and whatever the number is it
automatically the goals start breaking
down into math for you once they have a
time on them and an amount on them is
that logical to you yes sir yes sir and
I are not and I've read you know
Financial Peace University and one of
the things my pastor would always tell
me is that preparation has never lost
time so I think you know if I learn all
this stuff now once I get you know start
my career you know get married have
children you know all these things are
just all the things that I've that I've
put in place when I was younger
we'll just start just lining up when I
enter my order yes well what it amounts
to is is you're using utilizing a mental
muscle okay and you're developing that
muscle and what your point is valid in
that if you if you build up your savings
muscle and your budget muscle while
you're in college when you have a family
and have kids you have a savings muscle
to use it will look a little different
there'll be different zeros different
income amounts different savings amounts
different things we're doing but that
muscle is still there it's it's mental
muscle memory so to speak and so you're
just you're developing that part of your
character that that that maybe I didn't
grow up with or maybe you didn't grow up
with but we get that's part of growing
up as we develop some things that maybe
were not installed by our parents and we
can move beyond that and that's a cool
thing that's that's perfect nobody's
parents are perfect and so nobody's
upbringing is perfect so you just learn
something that you didn't have before by
developing that muscle and the cool
thing is is you know when you're doing
it at the college level with a part-time
job that's kind of like on training
wheels and then when you get the big job
now we're ready to ride the big bike
kind of thing and so you're exactly
right you're dead on track James very
cool you're going to be in great shape
man's honor to talk to you hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you